Hi, I'm Kevin Allocca.
I'm the trends manager at YouTube, and I professionally watch YouTube videos.
It's true.
So, we're gonna talk a little bit today about how videos go viral...
...and then why that even matters.
We all wanna be stars: celebrities, singers, comedians...
...and when I was younger, that seemed so very, very hard to do.
But now, Web video has made it so that any of us or any of the creative things...
...that we do can become completely famous in a part of our world's culture.
Anyone of you could be famous on the Internet by next Saturday.
But there are over 48 hours of video uploaded to YouTube every minute.
And of that, only a tiny percentage ever goes viral...
...and gets tons of views and becomes a cultural moment.
So, how does it happen?
Three things: tastemakers, communities of participation and unexpectedness.
All right, let's go.
Last year, Bear Vasquez posted this video that he had shot outside his home in Yosemite National Park.
In 2010, it was viewed 23 million times.
This is a chart of what it looked like when it first became popular last summer.
But he didn't actually set out to make a viral video, Bear.
He just wanted to share a rainbow.
Because that's what you do when your name is Yosemite Mountain Bear.
And he had posted lots of nature videos, in fact.
And this video had actually been posted all the way back in January.
So, what happened here?
Jimmy Kimmel actually.
Jimmy Kimmel posted this tweet that would eventually propel the video...
...to be as popular as it would become.
Because tastemakers like Jimmy Kimmel introduce us to new and interesting things...
...and bring them to a larger audience.
So, you didn't think that we could actually have this conversation...
...without talking about this video, I hope.
Rebecca Black's "Friday" is one of the most popular videos of the year.
It's been seen nearly 200 million times this year.
This is a chart of what it looked like.
And similar to "Double Rainbow," it seems to have just sprouted up out of nowhere.
So, what happened on this day?
Well it was a Friday, this is true.
And if you're wondering about those other spikes, those are also Fridays.
But what about this day, this one particular Friday?
Well Tosh.0 picked it up, a lot of blogs starting writing about it.
Michael J. Nelson from Mystery Science Theater was one of the first people...
...to post a joke about the video on Twitter.
But what's important is that an individual or a group of tastemakers took a point of view...
...and they shared that with a larger audience, accelerating the process.
And so then, this community formed of people who shared this big inside joke...
...and they started talking about it and doing things with it.
And now, there are 10,000 parodies of "Friday" on YouTube.
Even in the first seven days, there was one parody for every other day of the week.
Unlike the one-way entertainment of the 20th century,...
...this community participation is how we become a part of the phenomenon...
...either by spreading it or doing something new with it.